key difference between OA and what
happened yesterday yesterday who got
protected the depositors and they openly
said the shareholders and most of the
bondholders are screwed when I say most
of the bondholders the most senior
bondholders there may be some assets to
give them but the bottom level
bondholders and all the shareholders you
are wiped out back then remember Lehman
and bear went down but the rest of the
banks were saved last time they saved
the banks this time they've saved the
depositors last time they saved the Auto
industry the companies and only Alan
malale went in front of Congress and
said we'll take a loan but we don't want
to Grant Ford will be fine remember it
was the companies that were saved last
time the positives received it that's
foreign
[Music]